okay so my name is Jason Turner I've got
a few things going on there are some of
them I've got a podcast or at like 215
episodes now Rob everything and I do
this and C++ weekly my youtube channel
and MVP Victor and BPI sorry just have
to keep pointing it out because it's
awesome since 2015 I'm independent
available for contracting this is kind
of my sales pitch right but this is kind
of what my training looks like this is
the kind of level of interaction that I
want with people so please interrupt me
and ask questions and we'll see how this
goes but I can't really ask you to move
to the front there's an empty seat right
here and one right there thank you very
much okay if anyone is who's going to
see the pecan okay like two people I'm
giving a class they're coming up as well
no unapplied const exper okay so this
talk is about code smells let's take a
moment and talk about best practices and
if you were just here and Peter's talk a
few moments ago he mentioned the core
guidelines and coding standards books so
similarly I went and counted some of
these this is based on a grep of the
core guidelines and it looks like we've
got about 496 of them currently scott
Meyers effective modern c++ is at 42
that doesn't count Scott's effective C++
or more effective C++ or effective STL
books I've been working on my own best
practices website that's EPB best
practices com it's just a portable thing
on github there's about 109 things up
there so far C lossless coding standards
from herb Sutter and Audra Alex and
rescue 101 the best practices and that's
a fairly out-of-date book at this point
but I still like it
so I total
748 best practice items in just these
like four short things here there's a
lot of questions we have to ask how many
of them are unique does anyone have any
idea how many of those are actually
unique best practices now I just for the
record I I don't either I didn't count
them or anything how many of them are
like important how many of them are
critical to us writing good code how
many of them are stylistic concerns how
many of them you know really matter how
many of them can our tools
tell us about we'll discuss that more in
a moment
herbs made this comment it's VB con 2018
during his keynote he says we don't have
to teach the things all compilers warn
on I agree with them if we convince our
programmers to use warnings do you have
warnings enabled in your code
who has w all enabled and thinks that
means you have all of the warnings
enabled okay just for the record w all
is well unless you're talking a visual
studio ru Visual Studio developers yeah
yeah actually that's fun who all is a
Visual Studio developer in the room okay
and Visual Studio W all does mean all of
the warnings and clang in GCC it's a
tiny subset of the warnings actually
okay so I wanted to flip this around and
see what happens
if we just kind of look for code smells
like that do the smells help us reduce
the set of best practices to something
that we can actually stop and think
about instead of hundreds and hundreds
of things that we're trying to keep in
our mind all the time I asked Twitter
for their favorite C++ code smells and
which a lot of people think this is kind
of an ironic question how can you have a
favorite smell code smell
we don't think of code smells as good
things right they're not strawberries
and cream or something fright okay so
Ben Dean said constructions separate
from a
so code like this string and then we're
assigning it the string hello world and
I don't know because I've never given
this talk before how much I get to slow
down and like actually step into what
the codes doing so we're gonna see what
happens
I mean I've practiced the talk but so
this is with a very very latest version
of GCC with all optimizations enabled
this becomes a single return statement
that is actually really really
impressive this did not happen before
like a couple months ago or the previous
version of GCC let's flip over to claim
this isn't saying anything about
optimizers between different compilers
or anything what we are doing here
do we want to step through every line of
this no okay
like I said GCC did this like a month
ago right like this it's an arms race
and our compiler optimizers these days
so we are default constructing a string
on line 5 and then we are assigning a
value on line southern generally
speaking the compiler I'm actually very
surprised that GCC is optimizing this it
is two separate operations we have asked
it a default construct something then we
have asked it to call the assignment
operator on it so this is one of the
things that then complained about here
instruction versus assignment so better
is this construction and assignment if
you will in the same operation and now
GCC or clang it shouldn't matter this
particular build of clang that I have
installed at the moment has actually I'm
going to do it this way
this bit is it's a little bit of a
regression in the compiler currently
it's just not optimising out a couple of
stack operations don't worry about that
a whole lot but it's basically a no op
it's one reason I have GCC as my default
compiler at the moment for today all
right any comments on this it's really
simple straightforward stuff at the
start here Oliver he is our very active
on Twitter said out parameters this is a
typical out parameter we are defining
the value and then we are assigning the
value using a get value function you
write code like this used to okay so
same kind of deal we have to default
construct to the value and then we have
to pass it into this function to I fill
in its value this GCC we're setting up
the string we're default constructing it
or passing it by reference to the
function the the disassembly on line 10
is where we're actually calling the
function and then after that stack
cleanup and the possibility of dealing
with memory that had to be destroyed or
whatever we see two different deletes in
here the plan is not to step through
every line of assembly right but we can
oops I fast forwarded compared to this
version right here so again we are
getting the return value we're assigning
it we're doing this in one operation
anyone can tell me what this code
actually has to do here do we have any
copying of data happening no do we have
an assignment operation happening no if
I were to remove that constant of Al u
equals would it change the nature of
this code at all
I'm waiting for the person who answered
the last to would it I don't think it
would because either way it's going to
have to deal with the return value from
this function so if I return that yeah
code the optimized code stayed exactly
the same all right so I'm gonna give you
a little piece of swag okay how many
parameters does this function take one
what is the 1 the address of the return
value who's that it depends yeah so it
basically has to because a string well
it's a little bit complicated but
because the strings not like trivially
copyable and the size of a register and
all that kind of thing yeah it basically
is one we're gonna have to push the
return value of this function the the
the return memory location that is into
this function this is a function that
takes one parameter looks like a
function that takes zero it's a function
that takes one so this comes up Shawn
parents wrote an article on this stop
using out arguments construction verse
assignment kind of article that Sean
wrote a little while ago if you don't
know who Sean Perrin is you should watch
his videos read his articles good stuff
Sean is also a fan of saying there
should be no raw loops in our code he
did not respond on Twitter unfortunately
though I like to pace when I'm speaking
the camera at this point is not pointing
at me at all that's okay
raw loops don't express intent what does
this code do
I'm meeting using arranged for a loop I
could have made this harder to read if
I'd wanted to sex if if all the values
are within the range of 5 to 100 right
exclusive 5 200 I guess right and if it
is then we do some further processing on
the data let's flip this around and not
use arranged for loop let's use an
algorithm the more I look at code like
this the more I like it
line 12 I can read this like a sentence
if all of the values from the beginning
to the end are in range then process
more I don't even need actually the all
in range value at all if I don't want at
this point do you prefer this version or
this version who prefers option a who
prefers option B ok it's interesting I
still usually have a few holdouts from
people that are like no I don't like
functional algorithm things okay anyone
have any questions or any problem with
the lambda that I defined on line 7 it's
a lambda function I'm saying this is an
operation in range you could I could
have made it a free function doesn't
really matter for this case questions
all right Bjorn father's Bjorn in the
room Barnes not in the room okay twenty
veneered Peter Peter also left the room
they all said things like multi-step
functions I'm gonna leave this one up
for a moment for you to ponder this code
when I get a drink of water and you tell
me some things that you don't like about
it
this is actually derived from some
physics code that I was looking at
recently there's at least two bugs that
you should see and it probably compiles
without warning
yeah so on step two you're saying I
should have used toes here and I'm
comparing with pipes yes or I'm
multiplying by pipes all right what else
very similar code we don't like that
we're using intz yes which is doing what
probably in my code which which intz are
you referring to the control variables
so these ents are limited to 2 billion
hoses and pipes each approximately
because on every modern platform and
into signed 32-bit integer does anyone
work with datasets that are more than 2
billion items at once no one oh and it
does I didn't see your hand back there
kind of data set sizes do you work with
are you loud to say you cannot say ok
sometimes I do training at companies
that do things like database development
this comes up right you're like 2
billion items in a data proof that's
nothing right and then half of you are
like I do embedded programming 5
elements is a lot right that's the power
of C++ right it's everywhere ok
which one the values intent yeah okay so
I've got value as an int and I'm
returning a double which makes us
question the nature of this code
altogether right okay lots of things to
think about and reason about now Tony
and Bjorn and Peter all said things like
if they're reading a function and they
see the words
step1 step2 then it makes them want to
cry basically so they all went through
and grep all of their code bases and it
caused a little short thing in this
Twitter thread organs I call I'm so glad
I didn't find step anywhere in my code
base yeah that's the bug there so we can
flip this around I don't care if you
want to make this functions or lambdas
or whatever but now I can read this code
again as returned the total area of the
pipes with the total area of the hoses
plus whatever else thing needs to happen
in here this doesn't have to have
multiple steps in it one operation each
comment it's still two steps you're
saying here in here I don't technically
disagree with you but how would we flip
it around to like like can we literally
make this less than what's that yeah I
do believe you'd like a map or like
right okay this well you know what now
you're making me seriously question the
nature of this example because you
pointed that out are we better off here
than we were here
and it's kind of still two steps yeah
this is part yeah part of the problem of
trying to get it all to fit on one slide
to like I even struggled with okay how
big do I make each of these loops so
that it fits on a slide but I still have
a multi step function so that we can
argue about it all right
well we'll leave it out is because well
I'm not gonna live it at the slide at
the moment I asked though at this point
our comments necessary in this code
you're free to say yes just for the
record
yeah it is a specific area
implementation that is true yeah in this
accumulate area by the way is looking
for something that would be appropriate
for passing the to the accumulate
algorithm because it needs to take the
current area to this point and then
calculate the area of the next thing and
the operation so it might want to
comment that something like calculating
the area of a radius or something like
that okay this is something I ran into
this isn't from my my Twitter's non
canonical canonical operators this is an
operator overload for the comparison
operator of course for anyone who wants
to win this out and C++ 20 we will
actually get the spaceship operator
things that can do these for us but I
saw code that looked just like this
which is why it ended up on a slide like
literally just like this a couple months
ago and real live code so what are the
problems with it data should be const
and and the operator itself should be
const yes at least two constants missing
well like exactly two constant icing
code with conversions implicit explicit
cast like many many people commented on
this implicit conversions really get on
my nerves with this one which int is
which say comment from arnhem merits and
a follow-up from that he says this is
also known as the which int is which
interface with a credit to Edwin Brady
who I don't
to know you're familiar with interfaces
like this how often do you get the
parameter order incorrect do you have
any way of checking to see if the
parameter order is correct except for
tests so this was already pointed out
that we were doing implicit conversion
here although I must say I had the slide
up for a while before any of you said
hey wait a minute the value is an int
depending on your compiler settings you
may not get a warning from this you
probably will get a loss of precision
warning but we don't know actually if
the we presume probably that the hose
and pipe radii are floating-point values
not integral values because otherwise
multiplying by PI would be kind of a
waste ending questions all right so we
had conversions in at least one place
probably three loss of data in that code
this is one of my favorite examples I I
have written this code I have seen this
code have you written this code what are
we doing when we step through it here
we're getting a string on line nine and
then we're getting the C string of that
string on line ten and passing that to a
function expecting a string how many
strings did I just make this is easy to
do it's easy to get wrong it's easy to
the point that there's actually a
special check and Kling tidy
just for this specific mistake in your
code which Victor is well familiar with
you know you fixed a bunch of them yes
what happened by the way is you you have
this you string function that expects a
Const character pointer and then at some
point
you know cuz he wrote the code in like
2005 you go through and you're like well
you know what this should actually take
like a string because this is pre C++ 17
and then this line of code never got
refactored that's what happens by this
implicit conversion from a Const
character pointer to a string at all
can't I continues to compile a silently
with no no problem I am willing to bet
that this always exists in code that has
been around for a long time it is
somewhere in your code base all right
what is move at least one of my students
is in this class yeah what does move
it's a cast here take one of these test
that back I could have thrown it at you
but I'm afraid I would have actually hit
someone in the eye and that would have
been really bad move is a cast that is
all that it is it is an unconditional
cast to an r-value reference of the
given type so this is an unconditional
cast to an r-value reference of a string
thoughts yeah go for reader inhibits rvo
this forces a move instead of allowing
the compiler to optimize it this is the
pesum izing return by move prevents move
allusion this is a type of conversion
that is a code smell in our code
standard move itself is a code smell all
right what is returned from main
what's that whatever this is this is
undefined behavior you're not allowed to
modify an object that's been Const
defined constant during its lifetime
it's always a fun one to actually step
into because every compiler does the
exact same thing and an optimized build
completely ignores the constand an
unwise dilled and this is what makes it
really fun if you've never actually
looked at this is it sets up the object
on the stack it assigns the value four
on line four and then two lines later
let's see on line six it assigns the
value thirteen it has dutifully done
exactly what we asked it to do then on
line seven it returns four from main it
still completely ignores us modifying
constic during its lifetime is undefined
behavior Const cast is definitely a code
smell yes
does anyone have Const cast in their
code today yeah wipe your hand up for
everything is there anyone over here
who's using Const cast knowing you are
correctly probably not i've i've only
seen like to correct uses of it are
using it to talk to an old capi yeah
then you're hopefully doing it correctly
although I'm still leaning towards just
not making the object constant all when
passing it to a CA API so there's no
question because we have no way of
guaranteeing that that thing isn't
trying to mutate the data somewhere and
whatever library that you got from Hume
ever that's my conclusion at this point
all right
Bjorn said and Dimitar meet Jeff do you
midterm ensure it's that close does
anyone know okay he says they say code
with warnings I'm pulling this one back
up again can our compilers warn on this
yes they can we can turn on
our floating-point conversions our loss
of precision warnings we can get
warnings on this so yay that's good
can our compilers warn on this yes they
can now we have a pessimism move and
clang customising move finally from our
compiler that's good this one is one
that I ran into several times recently
and I just want to there's some question
about const global data in the last
session what are the implications of
using the static variable does anyone
know internal linkage yeah that's all
I'm going for what happens when line 8
of this function is executed right here
string is constructed the first time
what happens the second time it skips
how does it skip it it has a hidden
boolean variable we love being able to
click on examples and read what they're
doing let's just do this if you're not
familiar with compiler Explorer by the
way we can do this right click and
choose reveal linked code if we're so
inclined every single time this function
is entered it has to check a guard
variable to see if the string has been
initialized yet if it hasn't been
initialized it has to acquire a lock
guard and then has to initialize the
variable and free the lock it has to do
that check every single time we call
this function it's not an insignificant
amount of code that it has to generate
all compilers do this they're required
to do this this is thread safe
initialization of statics it is a
requirement of C++ 11 it's been
implemented in GCC and clang since
forever and Visual Studio in 2015 not
free
compared to this now I've cheated a
little bit because I also made these
string views but that's because I can
because you know what the name of this
function do things this is not changing
at runtime if it is you have other
problems in your code right so I made
this a string view and the advantage one
advantage making a string view is I can
make Const exper now and see this was 20
I could have made the string constants
for who gets to program and see what was
20 today yeah all right
who gets the program and Cee Lo's was 17
today yeah string view you have string
view you have context first support here
what does this code look like do I do I
now have to do a mutex check an atomic
check to see if this variables been
initialized nope that's all gone I get
to at compile time initialize the string
view object and pass it around
so static Const is a code smell that
should probably be context per and I say
that strongly actually I say probably I
should perhaps say likely it is it is
the only times that we have static
constat we can't make context whereas
things that we're doing dynamic
allocations on which at the moment we
can't do Const exper and maybe we don't
need those dynamic allocations in the
first place because it's probably
something that we know at compile time
and y-yes in 20 but oh you thought you
oh oh it's not allowed to leave the
context for context you're only allowed
to use it in the context or function at
compile time right yes so use string
view this is the right answer even and
see this was 20 Thank You Hannah
okay yes I do need to have it kind of in
this case sorry all right let's let's do
this actually let's see what we have
because at the moment I'm not entirely
sure I mean well I'll tell you what I'm
not sure about in a moment but let's
just leave this code and then I'm just
going to remove static and see if it
changes the generated code at all that
it did by one instruction that's not
helpful okay
contacts were static logically is
correct right we're saying do this at
compile time and it's a global value
from all the functions all the instances
of the or whatever all the calls to this
function older versions of GCC had a
regression where if I did not put
context for static it may actually
generate this object each time at
runtime even though it was constant Spur
it's allowed to do that actually because
the rest of this function is in a
context per function none of this is
being required to be done at compile
time
so is allowed to context for static
works well it is definitely going to do
it at compile time on all well
definitely going to do it at compile
time and all compilers okay that's sorry
for the air quotes oh and I was over
here so I don't know if the camera got
them just do Mike Alice times okay but I
think it's also logically there I think
who asked that question okay I think
it's it's it's logically the correct
thing anyhow right because we say this
is a global thing right it's it's static
for the lifetime of the pro
we want it done at compile time static
consoles a code smell should be constant
exper extern Const I saw this for the
first time ever just a few weeks ago
when I was preparing for this code that
looked like this X turn int Const and
then in a CBP file int Const value
equals 5 and then somewhere else
actually using this X turn int Const
what is this doing I'm gonna simplify it
it's approximately like this by the time
we've done the includes what does this
get value have to do so no no it's kind
of like we're telling the compiler I
have some really important information
to you for you that's known at compile
time but I'm not gonna tell you it's
really what it is if I do this every
single time this function is executed it
has to go somewhere to some memory
location and say what's the value of
that constant data that you should
already know that's just out of
curiosity raise your hand if you have
seen or written X turn Const what is the
logical reason for it how did it end up
in your code your hand is the highest
Oh is there okay so you yearn it you
know you're claiming no responsibility
for it yes misra or something no really
okay okay so for the sake of the rest of
you all he said it was already in the
code when he got there and then he
needed to add his own constants and he
didn't want to break the existing style
so he maintained the existing style of
adding more extern costs that fair and
the code is under restrictions could not
be modified too much can anyone tell me
like a good reason to do this because I
honestly truly don't know if one and I
just want to know if I'm missing
something okay you have a good reason
okay so you're saying you're you know
perhaps someone like but was this was
originally wrapped in a class or
something and they couldn't initialize
it in place and they or they're they're
used to that line of thinking which
fortunately we can do in C++ seventeen
inline initialization of static Kant's
data and in and can make inline
variables yes
using the linker to get different
applications is that a good application
maybe not okay all right so what's our
alternative though I mean besides just
initializing it in place right Const
exper this is C++ 11 right this is what
we want to do for the most part we want
to say Const X for int this is the value
this is or put an enumeration perhaps
depending on the application we're all
new and delete right that's bad right
you almost all raised your hands saying
C++ 17 or better or whatever so make
unique this is of course wasteful and
the heap should be avoided if possible
this is just an example we don't want to
use raw pointers if we can right so the
code smells that we have covered so far
our construction separate from
assignment output variables raw loops
multi-step functions
non-canonical operators code with
conversions casting away Kant's code
with warning static context turn Const
and ronu and delete have I done anything
yet to reduce the set of things that
we're looking for in our code because I
really just kind of touched on a bunch
of stuff are we better off yet I don't
think so
those are the yeah there's Lysa lots of
pictures taking it'll get better just so
you know all right this comes from
ACEF in the room no okay
this comes from a magazine that I bought
when I was at C++ on C and it has been a
magazine that has met me with very many
opportunities for code examples as a
magazine on learning how to program and
C++ this is one of the examples it makes
me so happy
okay all right let's do it
what now let's say for the sake of this
example we do want to keep three
separate variables here because this is
a teaching example about like
concatenating strings and stuff go ahead
talk to me what should I change first
line two
all right you want to get rid of using
namespace that's fine all right let me
get it compiling first okay know what oh
wait someone said line one wait what
line one I don't even need line one I'm
not printing this thing out okay what
was the next one and did your length as
opposed to what do you want me to do
with it you want me to do sighs T okay
I'll start with that all right now what
okay move the Declaration down here yay
life programming oh you want it Auto now
okay
all right Oh Stu we see we have a
problem still write the codes not
compiling hold on all right what's that
Oh which one do you want Const we'll
worry about that in a minute okay fine
one more one more on length is that what
you're saying okay now what else
anything else would like to change yeah
well I'm not actually doing anything
although technically C++ doesn't require
a return statement for mein that's
default zero this is not undefined
behavior for mein because it's special
but we may as well do something with the
value that we calculated I am honestly
super impressed with the latest set of
optimizations that GCC has managed to do
around string objects that's crazy good
that's crazy good we defined two strings
we concatenated them and calculated the
value and it threw it all away if you're
not impressed you really should be
that's I think new and GCC nine that
that's doing these things all right
would you change anything else I mean
assuming I don't know if you move I
think you walked in a second too late
Peter I was saying this is a teaching
example we're leaving the fact that
we've got three strings on here for the
sake of a teaching example well I would
change one more thing just because I
would do that
because I don't really care what the
result type of this thing is okay look
good
if I did the the S at the end then I
have to do using namespace literals
whatever I just I find it so tiring
I just prefer running stream most of the
time honestly but yes we could rearrange
it so that we're using the string
literals suffix okay I am now officially
moving slower than I meant to be so we
will go faster all right that was fun
now we ended up with mm maybe something
like that I didn't get rid of the using
namespace STD up there this one
factorial instead of live editing this
maybe take a few looks at this and tell
me like this reads input from the user
and then calculates the factorial just
yell out a couple things I should be
down and should be initialized factorial
arguably should be down to there's an
end line at the end of line 14 which I
just personally despise but then it's a
different topic entirely ok so
rearranging these values so that we can
initialize them what's our ultimate way
that we could actually initialize all
these variables and not have to define
something then assign a value to it
now I'm talking about like well okay how
about if we create functions that's what
I'm going for so this is a complete
compilable version of this I've got my
read input function it's a template
whatever because I'm just reading
something from CN but then I get down
here to main and I can say read the
input calculate the factorial of it and
print the values and by the way in this
case I am returning exit success from
main to keep things nice and kosher here
too
all right the conclusions that I ran
into working on this is that one thing
kept coming up over and over again that
had not explicitly been mentioned anyone
catched what it was I mean it came up in
the code reviews it came up in the
examples repeatedly whoever gets the
answer gets a car anyone anyone
here we run threat construction separate
from assignment what do we see Const
output variables what do we see Const
raw loops what do we see Const I'm
getting I'm trying to get everyone
talking together Const okay what kept
coming up Const kept coming up it's not
like this is the first time constants
ever mentioned at a conference just for
the record I'm not gonna claim any like
well I claim some responsibility for
this this is Kate Gregory marking
everything costs that you possibly can
not like oh I have to and then getting
away with whatever you don't have to but
turning it around and saying market cost
unless I absolutely can't because then
remember the compiler is your friend and
so anywhere that you have any kind of
errors of thought they'll be caught for
you know this is me anyone have any
ideas for how we might be able to get
this to use less overhead did I hear
context per I'm gonna pause right there
just for the record context was a little
bit of a joke at this point in 2016
today I'm like some cons decks for all
the things can anyone think of a simpler
way to get this to have less overhead
what's that pre compute a table yeah
that could work but constructs word kind
of get us there I think anyhow so is
there some best practice about using
Const anywhere possible does anyone ever
heard that so what happens if we make
our static or array here of color data
Const
okay so what actually happened there by
the way like I mean I have like three
years to reflect on this we made this
Const the compiler moved it into the
read-only section of the binary
therefore the compiler saw more
optimization opportunities and it ran
all of our standard algorithms and
everything at compile time simply
because it could I didn't even have to
use context for yet at this point yeah
so Const we want to use Const everywhere
that we can any lack of Const as a code
smell cons forces us into morganisa code
prevents common errors and encourages
the use of more algorithms now we have a
bunch of questions do we constitute I
have Const count in this code this game
who came to the meetup on Tuesday night
yeah this came up a lot right do i Const
this count why because I have a bug in
my code yes thank you Peter it does
change this code Oh
sorry because it doesn't change but it
does change the code did you see the bug
because I don't want it to change just
for the record I actually wrote this
code and then realized oh wait a minute
if Const had been on there would have
prevented this bug all right
so I'm incrementing count instead of
incrementing my index or whatever you
want to call it my counter all right
real err I've actually made this now
fails to compile it's intentional do you
Const temporary values what is what are
we doing here on line 8 we already
discovered this what does move it's a
cast to an r-value reference can I move
a Const object no this is a copy
oops I made it not Const oh no now it's
not constat face how do I resolve this
problem
don't have a temporary no reason to have
that value void the temporary altogether
or write a function functions are
amazing they've been around since when
who knows when functions were invented
Peter yeah I mean you were just kind of
talking about some of this I don't even
know what 1940s or something yet fun
aside our hardware is designed to make
function calls fast like since the 70s
are a late 70s early 80s Intel when they
were working on the 8086 said we want to
make we want to make algal like
languages fast on our cpu languages with
function calls ok is this ok
I see one head waving no why not as a
contact and we're trying to return it so
we don't want to do the standard move
thing here right because we already know
that that's going to revert to to a move
when it could be RV owed I will say this
actually is okay this does work with
return value optimization you always
have this it is the nature of calling a
function in C++ I you you will not be
able to show me a compiler to any
optimization level that does not use
return value optimization here going
back to 1997 at least because it's the
nature of how we call remember in the
version when I said how many parameters
does getstring take and we agreed one
it's because it's the location where
that value needs to look what about this
though am I am I am I getting returned
by optimization am i getting a copy or
am I getting a move here you say I'm
getting a copy it it is a copy yes and
since we're running out of time only a
little bit faster return value
optimizations not going to apply here at
worst case though is we actually have to
initialize value and value too and then
decide which one of them technically we
want to move out as of C++ 11 it's
equivalent to doing this but we can't
move a constant object they become
copies this however does fall back into
the case of return value optimization
interestingly because the scope is
limited to the return statement I don't
know if I can promise you that it will
on all platforms in this example but I
think it will of course we can avoid
this question altogether by avoiding the
temporary
I saw this code over and over and over
again in LLVM I started to compile a
Leeson version of clang just for this
talk and I saw these warnings pop past
so I saw this what is the warning that I
am getting from Ella from clang while
compiling clang on this line of code on
line 5 does anyone know oh okay what is
the value that I'd be getting from
playing here it is redundant move
because this is implicitly a move here
on line 5 as of C++ 11 does generate a
warning redundant redundant move and
return statement do week on Street earn
value types do I Const the string no why
what's that it's evil ok
it breaks move semantics yes it
apparently it used to be a thing to do
because this would fail to compile with
that work Const I never saw anyone
construe turned values before so I was
actually surprised to learn in like 2015
that this used to be a thing when I
started programming in 20 2002 or so
professionally it's an interesting side
effect of trying to make it behave more
like built-in types this is not this is
not compilable we can't do this in C++
so if we do this we get move assignment
on line 10 now of course how do we avoid
this question altogether initialize it
all in the same line like this so we
don't want to constantly return types
breaks move operations so my conclusion
ultimately as I found three smells just
for the record I really really wanted it
to be only one smell but I had to end up
with three missing and ignored compiler
warnings special checks for many of
these things
CVP check helps us reduce variable scope
variable can be Const tools can tell us
this the core guidelines checkers help
us reduce raw pointers and memory usage
Pesa maizing move warnings Const return
values in clang tidy
so that's smell one missing and ignored
compiler warnings number two missing
Const context / misplaced Const why
isn't that value con storm or member
function Const if it's known at compile
time it should be constant fur or an
enum this forces us into more efficient
more organized code where we utilize
array algorithms and numerix this is my
quote I am quoting myself here I don't
care if you use east const or west cons
just const your variables and i'm not a
triple a that's the almost always otto
i'm not a triple a fan but it does push
us in the same direction as const so if
we are using auto then we have to
initialize these values weak types and
casting this is unfortunate because
string file system path const character
pointers string views optional variant
shared pointer these all have these
implicit casts that exist in them unique
pointer does as well and this
contributes to many of these issues for
us unfortunately but we can try to use
strong or typing where we can we can use
options our numbers one and two here to
try to catch the rest of these issues
generally speaking we just have to read
our code try to use auto because Otto
doesn't coerce
types so that will prevent implicit
conversions you use correct types to
avoid casting and avoid naming
temporaries when we can so that we avoid
the standard move smell and I am out of
time to hit this bit well I have like
one minute left but just for the record
we can apply constant all the standard
algorithms all this doesn't have Const
we apply standard algorithm we get Const
and we make our own
algorithm so that's where I leave off
but with like two minutes left are there
any questions or anything you'd like me
to go back to right cool thanks Aaron
you